no PowerPoints are used inside of Amazon
new Executives have a little bit of
culture shock in their first Amazon
meeting because what we do is somebody
for the meeting has prepared a six-page
memo a narratively structured memo that
is got you know real sentences and topic
sentences and verbs and nouns not just
bullet points and it lays out and
supposed to create the context for what
will then be a good discussion so and
then we read those memos silently in the
meeting so it's like a study hall and we
do that everybody sits around the table
and we read silently for usually about
half an hour however long it takes us to
read the document and then we discuss it
the reason we read them in the room by
the way is because just like you know
high school kids Executives will Bluff
their way through the meeting as if
they've read the memo